und eine brandaktuelle meldung die uns
jetzt erreicht fahrt oxford forscher
hoffen wohl noch in diesem jahr auf
einen impfstoff zulassung natürlich
gegen das corona virus die bild aus
regierungskreisen erfahren hat soll die
bundesregierung wohl schon 54 millionen
einheiten dieses möglichen impfstoffs
reserviert haben weitere 18 millionen
dollar sollen dann optioniert worden
seien noch 2020 also in diesem jahr
könnte ein impfstoff gegen das curri und
nah virus also zugelassen werden und
genau darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen
mit herrn dr martin stürmers wir nun
zugeschaltet wenn man sich schon mal was
genau bedeutet das dass deutschland
jetzt sozusagen eine reservierung für
impfstoff hat ja das ist natürlich erst
mal gut und wichtig auf der seite ist
natürlich ein gewisses risiko weil auch
bei allem optimismus den die kollegen
oxford ja jetzt auch verbreiten ist ja
noch nicht gesichert dass der impfstoff
wirklich eine zulassung bekommt aber
insgesamt sind die signale ja doch eher
positiv zu bewerten
wenn es jetzt eine da sind sie dann wenn
es jetzt eine zulassung dafür geben wird
muss man sich dann trotzdem sorgen
machen weil es eben eine doch so kurze
zeit war oder können wir uns alle sicher
sein dass wenn dieser impfstoff auf den
markt zugelassen wird dass er dann auch
wirklich sicher ist ja zumindest ist das
kann kein impfstoff der zugelassen wird
ohne diese phase 3 studie wie wir jetzt
bei dem russland dem stoff gesehen haben
insofern können wir uns schon sicher
sein dass da deutlich mehr getan wurde
um wirksamkeit und sicherheit zu
überprüfen
natürlich bleibt ein gewisses restrisiko
weise natürlich die langzeit
nebenwirkung und auch die
langzeitwirkung mit einer relativ kurzen
studiendauer nicht geklärt wird es wird
natürlich weiter studien geben um diesen
impfstoff auch genauer charakterisieren
zu können auch wenn er die zulassung
schon bekommen hat aber insgesamt können
uns relativ sicher sein dass er damit
zumindest erstmal gut funktioniert und
keine nebenwirkungen 854 millionen dosen
sollen reserviert worden seien 18
millionen weitere dann als option wie
schnell könnte also jeder in deutschland
dann tatsächlich geimpft sein wie lange
dauert es um das dann zu verbreiten
das ist ja eine ganz spannende frage ist
gestellt haben mit der zulassung allein
ist es ja nicht getan sondern der muss
natürlich auch erstmal in diesen mengen
produziert werden
er muss in diesen mengen ausgeliefert
werden und dann eben entsprechend auch
durch impfprogramme an die bürger
verteilt werden und das wird sicherlich
mindestens wochen wenn nicht monate
dauern bis dann wirklich eine breite
verfügbarkeit des impfstoffs vorhanden
ist also bei einer zulassung ende des
jahres kann es dann trotzdem sein dass
wir erst im nächsten jahr tatsächlich
uns impfen lassen können
da gehe ich vor unterhaus ja